let's go to Dean from Dallas Texas Dean
welcome to the program what's on your
mind today
hey David can you hear me I can
uh I was wondering are you familiar with
South Korean politics at all only in
passing
so South Korea has kind of had a
historical problem with their presidents
they've sent Lee Myung back for
embezzlement and bribery he's gone to
jail for a long time parking has a
female president she's been to jail for
abuse of power bribery coercion leaking
government secrets even the former
president Moon he's under investigation
he he could go to jail my question is to
um
why a democratic country like South
Korea has no issues Prosecuting and
jailing former presidents and
politicians politicians but the U.S
can't
do you think culture and tradition Trump
law I do I do and you know if you go to
my birth country of Argentina you'll see
there is also a long tradition of uh
corruption and arguable criminality from
presidents and leaders and uh the the
last one the previous one seems almost
always to be under investigation and the
Dynamics within countries I think
sometimes maybe the right term is that
there are these
uh over time implicitly it's not like
people sit down and say here we jail
former leaders and then in another
country people sit down and say here we
do not jail former leaders I believe
that it's small decisions over time that
are a combination of
how the judicial system and court system
the Judiciary is set up
how judges are chosen
uh cultural attitudes towards misdeeds
by elected officials all these little
things together lead to some countries
where it's completely typical that uh
you you jail former leaders and others
where you don't it also exists in the US
at the state by state level I mean look
at New Jersey's history of Prosecuting
former governors which I mean you could
say well they've had a lot of more
criminality among former Jersey
governors compared to another state but
there also seems to be something there
about expectation so I think it's all of
these things
okay so you think like the fear of
public retribution or violence impacts
our justice system that I don't know
specifically it's it's possible that's
possible but we'd really have to ask
more to understand people's attitudes
but I think there is a cultural
component and there's also a sort of
cumulative component over time related
to expectations
okay well thanks for uh taking my call
all right Dean from Dallas thank you
very very much for the call
friend or loved one who is passionate
about the environment here is a perfect
holiday gift our sponsor established
titles is a project that lets you
ceremonially purchase as little as one
square foot of dedicated land in
edelston Scotland so that you can call
yourself a lord or a lady like the
historic Scottish tradition some people
even change their plane tickets or
credit cards to include Lord or lady
your title pack comes with an official
certificate you can see exactly where
your plot of land is located it makes a
perfect last minute gift but most
importantly established titles plants
one free tree for every plot of land
sold established titles does really good
work all over the world with
reforestation organizations like one
tree planted and trees for the future so
you'll have a great laugh whether you're
Scottish or not I'm not but you're
giving the gift of deforestation to
fight climate change if you use my link
you'll get 10 percent off and your plot
of land will be right next to mine you
can see it on a map go to
establishedtitles.com Pacman and use the
code Pacman for an extra 10 off on top
of their Black Friday deal the link is
down below